hello again hopefully I'm slightly more
calm in this video but I just wanted to
go over a few things if you haven't seen
my last video there'll be a card right
about 9:00 so Andre duck's in his back
he according to modern Erasmus he has
been extraordin the Russian branch of
the SCP wiki a question that I got
yesterday was what does this actually
mean if he succeeds in doing what he
wants to do
what are the consequences so I haven't
spoke to modern Erasmus who was the
author of the original post the main
thing is he could obviously take time to
Russian SCP wiki that's quite a large
wiki in comparison to international SCP
wiki's the possessions of all the other
wiki's could be threatened night what
does that mean as it's been explained to
me if Andre dachshund succeeds and
turning the Russian SCP worki into his
personal merchandising platform it sets
a really bad precedent the reason that
me and pretty much every other SCP
content creator is getting on top of
this pretty much as soon as we can is we
and I'm sure every single person
watching this video now does not want
that to happen because as we all know an
agree on SCP is a community based funded
written and executed project no one
single person gets to own any part of it
we make our own content around it but
it's all distributed under creative
commons share-alike 3.0 and that's where
it stops so if he succeeds in this it's
a really bad precedent and that's not
something that this community or our
content creators or the wiki staff
globally are gonna tolerate so this is
why I'm not gonna shut up defender it
there's something I've seen recently on
that website VK I don't know if you
remember it from the update video this
is what he posted on one of the
discussion threads on this website so
obviously this is in Russian but I've
been told the translation is and by the
way if you're Russian and you really
good at translating feel free to correct
me below but I've been told that this
comment means in response to the massive
media
average he's getting right now he has
said yes is going to get the fight one
man me so many people are frightened of
me
amazing is it will be when they fail to
win against me and the Russian branch of
the foundation will be wiped from the
face of the earth that's apparently what
it says I mean as you can tell he's very
confident so this is the kind of
attitude that Andre has about
potentially destroying the fandom that
we all love it's pretty upsetting to be
honest as you can tell I mean yesterday
I was quite angry I tried to remove all
personal opinion from it and I'm still
gonna do that and that brings me on to
my final point obviously I've decided to
make a new video just to bring this to
the top your subscription box but the
donation links will be in the video
description the Pend comment and I'm
gonna tweet them later on your donation
will go towards legal fees hopefully
that will be an open-and-shut case
because this kind of stuff cannot and
will not be tolerated
I hope the entire community has made
this abundantly clear so just to show
you I'm putting my money where my mouth
is I've donated $100 to this and I
encourage you to donate whatever you can
and not saying everybody has to donate
$100 it's just this fondant means a lot
to me and the fact that people are
trying to destroy it really annoys me so
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you're all dismissed
goodbye